[Music]
do you guys have dark times do you have
times when you where you get down and
how do you deal with that absolutely
um
yeah i've had some pretty rough chapters
um
i don't know probably
clinical depression for all i would know
i've never been diagnosed but yeah you
go into those
you go into those
those ruts
being selfish you know you you put in
all this effort and you want to see the
goal post move just a little bit you
know what i mean and
and that's not the way that it works you
know you just you sow the seed you know
you nurture it you water it you do what
you can do but when it bears fruit you
know that's at a time that has
absolutely nothing to do with me it's
not about the amount of effort i put
into it but i think the selfish side of
you when you're when you're striving so
hard and you're trying so hard and you
want to see something move and it
doesn't it can be a pretty rough place
to get into and then of course we deal
with all the same things that everybody
else out there on the outside is dealing
with losing loved ones and family and
those can be some some very very dark
times
you have like
more degrees i think than any person
i've ever seen you know like and like
you know like what what are some certain
things that you can touch upon that were
like that you're like i'm on the right
path i look from somebody somebody that
you were able to help like what are some
specifics well for me um i first decided
to try to do college because nobody in
my family's ever done it and the call
and the prisons were offering it so i
seen it as a benefit because in the
streets i wouldn't have been able to
afford it
and i always loved to read especially
about history about political science so
now
i could try to get a degree so
i first my goal was to try to do a class
or two and even just pass the class
uh after that those were short-term
goals
that build up my self-confidence build
up uh my just
built me up that i could do
what i set out to do then i decided to
see if i could get three or four degrees
and
that led to the fifth one
and so
each little small goal was a a stepping
stone to
helping me change with everything you
learn you slowly change no matter what
you we age out of crime and we age out
of uh ignorance too and
for me
those uh those goals helped me
with uh
learning how
how i was raised and how
the positive factors in my
in my youth
help
first of all take responsibility for
what i did but i i started learning
about positive factors and contributing
factors that led me to be the person i
was well what are those factors um
some of the things is running in the
streets uh
being easily influenced by people that
said they loved me and they protected me
these were strangers in the streets at
first
they would see a little six-year-old
seven-year-old just kicking out there in
the streets just looking for whatever he
could
um at the beginning it was food they
would feed me and
make sure nobody would mess with me and
then later on
uh
teach me how to steal and
told me if i wanted anything i would
have to take it and it was just small
warp beliefs that
seemed to uh find a
root in my mind that continued to
progress as as i got older that led me
to the gang life that led me to continue
my uh
depending on other people other than my
actual family because they were never
around um
it led
me to
depend on other people more than my own
family even though
it wasn't their fault
they were just trying to make a living
and
it's just
at the time i didn't have no tools to
deal with the inadequacies that i had
you know or
asked anybody for the help that could
have maybe helped me uh
even deal with some of the problems that
i was dealing with
so
if you could if you could
you know talk to that that version of
yourself now and i guess in some ways
you have opportunities to do that what
what would you guys say to your younger
selves
dad i love him that you're loved
you know
that your mom is doing everything she
possibly can just to put a roof over
your heads uh not to give in to
to the temptation because that's what it
was these false beliefs that
she was sacrificing her time just so
that we could have a
a roof over our heads and food in our
table
um
i i was seeing it like it was an
abandonment because she was always gone
if i could just tell him hey just
stick it out just
just
stick it out you you would be okay
she loves you that's the reason why
she's working though as much as she is
um i didn't know that at the time i i
thought she didn't love me because
after my dad split or went to prisons
here i
i even try to make excuses but he never
split he continued selling drugs and he
went to prison and got deported never
decided to try to come back i i held on
to uh his anger toward him for the
longest
because of my
when i got older when i got to 16 or 17
it was uh
he made my life and my mom's life more
harder
my mom had to send my older brother and
older sister to go live with uh with our
ballerinas because she couldn't take
care of him and us at the same time
so to for me it was always an
abandonment issues that
once they left i didn't have them no
more so it to me it was constant losing
somebody and not having them so
if i could tell them may everything will
be okay just
everything will work out i would tell
him that and that he's loved
the same
i would uh i would tell that younger me
that uh
you know that you're enough
like who you are
like
not the version that
you think everybody wants you to be
um
i had some pretty
some pretty warp beliefs around you know
i became a father at age 17 right my son
was born when i was 17 and i believe
that's one of the he talked about
causative factors but a contributing
factor
that contributed to me actually making
the decision to commit my crime
was being a young father
and
when you normalize crime within a
community
i almost felt like it was an honorable
thing to take from somebody else to
provide for mine
and
that that young individual that's that's
where his head was at so i would first
and foremost i would tell them that you
know you are enough the the image that
you're seeing in other people like
everything that glitters ain't gold you
know a lot of these people they're
projecting an image but they're
they're probably feeling the same way
that you are that's why they you know
over inflating their ego
so
i would tell them that you're enough um
everything that that glitters is in gold
i would tell them that you know
being a father is more about being
present and setting a good example then
ensuring that you know your son has
jordan jordan's on his feet or you know
a closet full of you know um diapers and
whatever it is that you need um
those are the things that i would tell
that that younger individual
[Music]